[Music]
foreign
do you think i'm going to sleep tonight
when i see this
do you think i'm going to be able to
just close my eyes
and sleep why don't i just sleep forever
[Music]
[Music]
this time i can't believe it i'm 40
years
this country but i can't believe it is
[Music]
[Music]
stores at the small in diplov in soweto
have been entirely ransacked there's
nothing left
and now soldiers and police have been
deployed to places just like this
to try and protect whatever little is
left
and also keep looters away but
preventing the looting in many areas in
johannesburg
has proven difficult and appears to be
impossible to stop
i don't know where am i going to buy
food
i don't know as you can see that it's
bad
and there's the situation people are not
working
but this is not the solution
[Music]
now i'm angry because where what am i
supposed to do from now
where am i gonna get paid where is my
salary gonna come from
because this is my livelihood how am i
gonna support my family because of this
and the criminals that have been
rampaging these places
and the police were nowhere to be seen
you